[Musique]
e
mohamed nagui
[Musique]
le milieu de l'année good the bad il ya
un mois alors passionné par le foot
magazine ne rate jamais une coupe du
monde que ce soit au brésil en australie
en métropole milliers de se déplacer
vers les membres ici est parti en russie
dernièrement vu lors des derniers
matches zuma il a un club qui fait du
sport en du corps et même à la réunion
et suit les matchs de foot se déplace
pour la saint pierroise passionnés du
web
maintenant les mini un nouveau roi vie
qu'ils ont gros travail mais le goal com
* de vaumas battons aussi parce que
monsieur masure a toujours aimé mener
des projets il a fait d'abord de
l'activité athétisme après il a fait de
la bonne chère il se donne toujours pour
son club que tu réaction si elle me
posait zone euro il vit comme invalide
poilpré unis mènent un combat phénoménal
pour le comité régional handisport pour
son association pour tous les personnes
handicapées de son club
voilà maintenant pour moi c'est ça
le monde meilleur bien sûr la paix et
aussi que la belote dans le monde hors
l'activité et la pratique du sport pour
tous qui est ce nous qui l'avons oui
pour la vie
[Musique]